I feel it tails from the comment section
is coming well when you're right you're
right from the comment section my rating
system explained Wow
one of the most unnecessary videos ever
created still liked it though well if
you watched it and liked it is it really
unnecessary one for the philosophers I
suppose this video makes me believe that
Jeremy is actually brimming with
optimism I really like that well you try
to be optimistic I don't always succeed
but I try to be optimistic because I had
my stint of misery when I worked retail
management now that that is behind me I
just being optimistic and having a
positive outlook on life it's just
better for you as a person than the
miserable rat so if you can just be
optimistic there's a bright side to any
situation sometimes hard to find but is
there am I the only one who remembers a
tour-de-force rating what about Oscar
worthy hey good news first guy you're
not the only one who remembers it
apparently but yeah I used to have a
rating called tour-de-force or Oscar
worthy it's it was ultimately for those
Oscar bait movies I found boring but
everyone else loves I don't know I might
still use it one day who knows the
problem with you Jeremy is you're not a
movie critic you're a movie and well
thank you but you misspelled coolest
thing about here I'll help you there you
go I love you too man been here since
2010 and always gets that well thank you
appreciate the love and admittedly I am
cautious if not conscious of the idea
that my channel could become stagnant if
I just review this movie review that
movie review that movie just rinse and
repeat every week so I try to
incorporate new elements into it to make
it feel fun to keep the creative juices
flowing hence that's right tales from
the comments actually takes five times
longer to edit one of these than a movie
review but it's also a little more
creative and I like that I'm going to
forget this video in t-minus two days
while watching a movie I bought on
blu-ray if I'm getting drunk without
alcohol required as I eat awesome
tacular dog [ __ ] well then you are my
kind of crazy so if you feel like some
movies can't be rated properly with any
of your titles why not add in one or two
should be fine yeah think about my
rating system that I personally like is
a
but it does lend itself for me making
[ __ ] up it's like here's a new rating
for that movie here's a new one for that
movie new one for that movie it might
confuse people I don't know now that
they have a video mapping out the rating
system as long as they keep it in mind
that the point is yes thumbs up thumbs
down is a good is it not I'm not opposed
to making new ratings every once in a
while I don't see what happens I always
try to guess what Jeremy's rating is
before the review ends I've got a pretty
good track record right is the best part
who doesn't love trying to guess the
writings it's fun you're not being
particularly douchey today I will say
that you're being quite civil I thought
your writing system was pretty
self-explanatory guess it's baffling for
some and we're back with douchey yeah
well this is a perception things as
people are different
what's self-explanatory to one person
might not be so self-explanatory to
another person just people assimilate
information differently some people are
good at math some people are good at
English some people are good at science
if you're good at one you might not be
good at the other two you might be good
at two but not the other one you might
be good at all three you might be good
at none of them so it's just like what's
common sense to one person might not be
common sense to another what's easy for
one person to understand might not be so
easy for another so just a video was fun
to do it was worth it I wanted to inform
people glad I did it
but everything is better when you're
drunk everything are you sure like
driving are you saying drunk driving is
better you don't say that on the
internet this is a good time for me to
say if you're gonna drink drink
responsibly if you're gonna drink at all
please do not drive while intoxicated
and stop [ __ ] eating Tide Pods you
look ridiculous why did I eat iPod
seriously about the time pot that's the
dumbest thing I've ever said yeah why do
you eat soap poisons of Darwinism at its
finest you wouldn't drink bleach would
you this is a good time for me to say
please do not drink bleach why do I feel
like I have to give these disclaimers on
the internet in the dark time we live in
that dark times okay but can a dog [ __ ]
movie be a better with alcohol tried
that with Mortal Kombat annihilation sad
to say it does not always work it's what
you're saying is I should just make like
three second videos and just say yes or
no about a movie and that's it well you
could but like I said there'd be no
context which if you want to make short
reviews for the risk of the sound like a
shameless plug there is that Stardust
app that I like to use you can do quick
30-second reviews that are to the point
I've kind of figured out that after I
watch a movie I can do a Stardust
reaction and it won't compromise my
YouTube review kind of like leads into
it you know they were kind of in tandem
and it's fun so if you follow the link
below you can download the Stardust app
follow me on it you actually do your own
reviews too it's easy to do makes it
better however you do have to make it
more than three seconds so I think it
has to be above three oh you're like a
five-second review it's fine alright
that is it for another episode of tales
from the comments-section a segment I'm
having fun doing I'm glad you guys enjoy
it like I said it's a little different
than my review so if you can go ahead
and give this a like send it out there
on your social media it really does help
me out a lot and keep the comments
coming I'll see you for the next episode
did you have fun study yes oh he's doing
it okay alright and if you like what you
see in here anymore click right here to
see more somehow that was actually well
said
[Music]